a novel is not a logical thing and it
doesn't come from a logical place it
comes from a really emotional place the
idea or the screenplay is a plan you
have a plan you have to tell a story
within about a hundred pages and it has
to move this way and that way and there
needs to be some sense of resolution and
it has to have this kind of narrative
flow that a book doesn't and so you know
in a way it's very easy to write a
script compared to a book I think part
of the reason why me maybe scream
writing is not as much fun as writing a
book is that it you have to adhere to a
formula and stylistically it doesn't
matter how it's written and ultimately
it's the blueprint for a medium where
the director and the actors are more
important than a script and it's
collaborative you get notes from
producers you get notes from people who
have a lot of money who want to put
their imprint on the film and you get
notes from a director who once you know
three four five more polishes before
he's ready to shoot and so it's a it's a
collaborative process and a novel is not
a collaborative process and there are
there are I think pleasures uh to both
mediums and I like working them both but
I but you know it's a good point I mean
did it has it affected my writing
writing you know so many scripts I don't
think so because I don't look at a novel
as a thing that I want to turn into a
movie I mean the novels that I write are
really just literary based I mean I I
think of them as books first and
foremost and I don't think of them as
anything else
you